I wanted a new life I wanted to start  over that's what I did but somehow I  made things worse so I decided to run  back in time again and let things happen  things are back to how they should be  well I guess you'll just have to wait  and find out  where's iris they don't talk Barry you  know that I need your help  Jesse your speed sir and I just wanted  things back to how they were fixed if  you wanted things fixed maybe you should  have gone back in time and stopped my  brother from dying you battery  I think that everyone that had powers of  Flashpoint is gonna get them back  futures changed our sauce avatar murder  I have powers what kind of powers  the cool kind these headlines thought  they they tell us what happens in the  future where Caitlyn becomes killer  frost and higher skies if we can change  the headlines that means we can change  the future that's right  challenge accepted  [Music]  you